m
385 millions d'euros c'est la somme
validé par l'union européenne dans le
cadre du pdr air programme de
développement rural de la réunion pour
la période 2014 2020
une enveloppe conséquente à laquelle
s'ajoute la part de l'état à hauteur de
130 millions d'euros comme l'a souligné
serge hoareau conseiller départemental
en charge de l'agriculture
cette décision est une grande
satisfaction d'abord vous dire que
c'était un document à une validation
attendue par la profession agricole et
depuis le 25 août nous avons eu donc
cette chance d'avoir cette validation
ce qui va permettre de libérer les fonds
européens en direction des acteurs
locaux du monde agricole
c'est une première satisfaction parce
que c'était un travail de longue haleine
porté par les services départementaux et
ce travail aujourd'hui porte ses fruits
nous allons rester dans un planning
contre 1 jusqu'au fin octobre puisque
nous avons créé un comité national de
suivi organisé et un comité local de
suivi pour valider l'ensemble des
critères et des fiches actions et très
rapidement nous allons dès loin devant
pouvoir commencer à libérer les fonds en
direction de l'encadrement technique qui
était qui a fait l'objet d'un appel à
projets sur l'animation des eaux sur la
mise en place de l'observatoire des eaux
un certain nombre de d'action maintenant
vont pouvoir être engagées sur la base
de ce nouveau programme européen les
nouvelles responsabilités du conseil
départemental devenu autorité de gestion
l'ont amené à créer un service dédié
permettant une efficacité améliorée de
la gestion et du pilotage du programme
je crois qu'il ya eu un temps nécessaire
de travail
un temps nécessaire de validation
maintenant que document est validé on va
pouvoir avancer en toute sérénité et
c'est ce message que je veux lancer en
direction du monde agricole
soyez sereins le conseil départemental
autorités de gestion travaille pour ce
qui est certain c'est que les services
du département sont en ordre de bataille
pour maintenant à les instruire
l'ensemble des demandes dead que cela
concerne l'encadrement technique comme
on vous l'a dit mais également
l'animation des halls la gouvernance des
eaux ou encore la mise en place de
l'observatoire
une étape et l'organisation d'un comité
national de suivi les 5 6 et 7 octobre
prochains